and Jay Glazer back on the show how you
been Jay are you I'm good where have I
found you thank you you're in you're
busy I'm just I'm just leaving Rams camp
okay madam cavil at camp but I gotta
kind of chime in here I think you guys
are missing the boat I think it's the
lefty north why I think the Packers got
even stronger which is pretty scary
finance and some of the moves they've
made and then the Bears now a next year
under it was true Biscay they're under
the lions now with Patricia will be
gonna have a different attitude there in
the Vikings
they're already stronger than getting
you know good back I think that's going
to be a really tough division well let's
let's sling around the Bears hear it a
little bit cuz we're all viewing into
the second year of Jubilee with Matt
Negi something similar or the the
situation you just left right there with
what the Rams were able to do how real
is that though in Chicago Jay I mean
look anytime when you have a young
quarterback you have a what you're
bringing in is you think as an office of
guru there's always going to be a lot of
you know high hope but for Biscay last
year like right when they brought him in
there like how we're gonna let him it's
you know we find Glennon we're gonna
really take him along slowly but he like
they almost they they stacked it up so
much we're the only way something could
happen if he absolutely blew the doors
off and he did from like day one he
picked stuff up so much faster than they
expected he did things you know during
practice which wow them over and over
and over and that obviously wasn't the
case with Goff its first year so it's
kind of almost is he's starting from a
higher basement if you will than golf
did
and now here's naggy coming in with the
with players that they can try and make
work I mean Alan Robinson being healthy
I guess right - Rico and having a great
first year Jordan Howard being being a
threat out of the backfield - yep but
also the one thing you have to be
careful of is everybody is trying to
hope they get the next Sean McVeigh and
there is no next on the gray he's
different
I mean he's a different cat rich he he's
a rare guy will connect with the
Millennial who connects with Andrew
Whitworth who connects with Wade
Phillips he's different and just the way
he goes about everything it's you know
yesterday camp he actually he did
something I've never seen before he
stopped he ended up the first practice
early good guys and you know normally
rich you've been around a lot these
coaches that first day they try to beat
the crap out of you they really want to
kind of set that tone that first day and
he went the other way he said man these
guys you know they nerve up the first
day things are sloppy because some guys
are trying to prove something right off
the bat some guys are just trying to get
in their groove and he's like I just
want to protect these guys more it's the
first time I've ever heard a coach say
yeah you know guys really nerve up first
day and it would look you're the fear of
the unknown is brutal on your nerves if
you go in for any and I'll equated to
you'll fight him when you first in first
ever you know you gonna spar you your
nerves gets you when you also and run
out of punish you you can't breathe it
like two minutes and if you go do the
same thing the next day you'll be fine
for like ten minutes
so I he just sees things differently
than I've seen in a long time
well there's no doubt that the ceiling
and the expectation level is tremendous
for the Rams this year and they have the
personnel and the code I love McVeigh -
I'm with you Jay less need the whole
situation Wade Phillips being in charge
of the defense top to bottom
Aaron Donald being there could put him
over the top what is going on there and
and the concept that he's not gonna play
another down under his current contract
means that there's a deadline coming
real soon
real fast what's going on there Jay
we've seen these happen over and over
and over again I just think they're so
far apart right now but you know where
they always work themselves out don't
they well it's your guy you always got
warm people to like look
you're gonna get in a public spat it's
gonna be bad but you gotta remember like
at one point you're gonna be married
again so you can't sit there you can't
sit there and do the whole thing of you
know it's like when you break up with a
girl and also and all your friends tell
you how much they hate the girl and then
you get back with her and you're like oh
no all your friends are like God now
we're out of them we're out of the
circle of trust just say that you'll get
back you know it's it's gonna be rough
for a little while but they know that
means the best defense Clara tallit I
know and it's not like it's not like
they're not trying to paint him as one
of the best defensive players in the
league if not the two best paid player
on that side of the ball in the league
but what so what is what is the the gap
I think he's gone for because I think
you know Aaron will probably go for hey
I'm not just defensive player let me go
try and get quarterback money or you
know one of the best players in the
league type money and it doesn't mean
you're not gonna eventually get to where
you're supposed to go you know again
we've made which we've seen as a million
times where somebody shoots so
incredibly high and the team is like
I'll forget this will never work and
then the team shoots so incredibly low
and the player got so ticked off and
then 14 years later that player retires
as a member of that team and makes all
of it it happens all the time Jay Glazer
here making his way from Rams camp to
cowboys camp what what do you think
you're gonna see when you get to cowboys
camp Jay what's there oh good question
no idea that's why I'm going up you know
it's so funny to rich every time I go to
all these camps like a coach or GM
welcomes me and I say the same thing
over here though the company will go
after that first practice ago so what do
you think of our team
what would you see out here today and I
say the same thing every year I'll go be
honest with you guys
um see you guys are gonna suck this year
look at what I go I don't know what I
don't want to look at anybody here for
two hours right what are you asking me
for
hey good but it's like at least I know I
don't know I don't know what they're
working on and you know you see all
these things like oh this court of
activists you know he there's five
passes dropped or this
this is the time you're supposed to
screw up its training camp when you're
working on stuff I don't know what
they're working on but at least I know I
don't know right so I guess then I let
me let me hone that question in the
Cowboys the Cowboys need to improve
we're the most do you think J obviously
you get you get back back and you're
three Zeke for the full 16 with nothing
hanging over them the question for the
Cowboys in terms of making the playoffs
or not what do you what do you have what
do you think they're I think we all know
that means defense where you need to
need you obviously need that pass rush
to to just be to be a real nuisance in
that division and there's you know
problems with a lot of guys on that
front of that line right now so they've
got to figure that out
they gotta figure out a way to generate
an awful lot of pressure on the
quarterback and I think that'll say what
happens there Jim and then you know
obviously the way that the the NFC East
could be the best team in in the in the
whole league we've got the defending
Super Bowl champs there you're on the
way to Cowboys the Giants I could you
have to assume they're gonna be several
games better than last year yeah and
John Merrow saying that they're ready to
talk contract with Odell the question is
is he going to take the approach of levy
on bail and Aaron Donald or is he gonna
take an approach like let's say similar
to one for his position that Todd Gurley
just did taken he s taken a position of
Donovan and he's there you know and yeah
I think that you know girls it was
different
he's different is it isn't a different
position because he's such a he's such a
superstar you know you gotta weigh
against skill versus circus and it's
always the circus around him but Danny
has so much skill and there's not mean
bone in his body you know it's not like
he's one of these guys you just me me me
and you know forget my teammates and I
don't work hard and selfish it's not
like that he works his butt off you know
teammates let me he's a lovable do to be
around but it will be interesting
because yeah I mean he's you know some
of these guys also were looking
cells in contract no hey I'm not just a
player I'm a I'm a brand and well team
doesn't care if you're brand enough they
just care what happens in the field
so it'll and what happened this
offseason with him potentially getting
traded with Pat Shermer who's like I do
not want to get rid of him I don't want
and you know if you're going to trade
them this was the time to do it we're in
you know we're in an impasse just wait
his contract was this was the time to do
it and Pat from day one did not want to
do it new week that's a real he's a
great coach in a way that he is always
above drama he's kind of Switzerland
with everything he sucked look he was
Eagles with Chip Kelly when all that
went down he was the Vikings when north
turner left he's been through it a lot
obviously the Browns but he's always
remained above board with everything and
I think it's it's really impressive and
that's the way he connects with people
and for him to that hotel situation was
really really murky for a while and I
don't know how many coaches will be able
to smooth it out the way this has been
smooth out last one for you then for the
moment because I want you on as much as
you're willing J and I know you is that
I'm not gonna ask you for that breakout
star this year like who's the Kareem
hunt or chimera or whatever I want to
know from last year who's gonna take
that big step one of those kids that did
well last year that you think is poised
to just go through them I think I think
from our Minnesota oh man he is he's
different but he's a he's a game breaker
easy man healthy you think yeah I think
it'll be good yeah I mean ACL to storm
like they used to be so I just think if
they can get him there and he has
confidence in it he is a he's a
difference maker you want to ask Jay
Glazer the poll question you want to go
music with jack yeah let's do glaze
what's the best original movie
soundtrack so today's the 34th
anniversary of Purple Rain so that's on
there with Saturday Night Fever
eight-mile frozen and Top Gun frozen in
their rich program
do not but frozen is I mean up I'll pray
on the table for frozen but I did not
put them in there I'm gonna have to vote
for Moana just because my political
allegiance Moana by the way is a great
Lingam well Miranda soundtrack agreed
but would you uh would you take right
there no see that's gonna be obscure so
I can't say this oh man I'm surprised
you didn't put dirty dancing up rich I'm
a little I'm a little I said that but I
said that prior to the show but the
reason why is because a lot of song
compilations have to be original songs
the original yeah Straight Outta Compton
not even closed there you go I bet that
wasn't made original for the film right
those that's all just music that look at
your world where rent pain that's it
okay wait wait go back give me the
option again okay give it again
Purple Rain Saturday Night Fever eight
mile
frozen Top Gun I'd say it's between
Purple Rain and eight mile
what's it what's all right now probably
to say purple right what do you got
Purple Rain thirty-four percent right
now else Saturday Night Fever 25 percent
eight miles 17 percent Top Gun 13
percent frozen 11 personnel I put top
gun in there and frozen is uh it's
taking it in the shorts vets and players
org just to give everybody an update on
what's going on with the vets and player
merging vets and players and man it's
been great you know again we we've had a
really phenomenal last couple weeks with
fourth of July we asked all our veterans
and people out there to know the
chariots vets and players we take former
combat vets and former pro athletes who
both need a new team when the uniform
comes off we kind of empower them again
to use their scars for the next step of
life and I asked our vets give me
something that makes you proud of
yourself for your service eyes we're
celebrating you on 4th of July and our
end
today we need something from you that
helps you celebrate yourself and our
vets couldn't answer the question they
kept going around the room and and while
we're proud to be MVP no it's not what
I'm asking
give me something makes you proud of
your service and then we kind of realize
that our guy started talking well that
side single part of her issue is that
we're ingrained not to have
individuality so I am in that room our
veterans we're now trying to help other
veterans gain their individuality like
be proud of something from your service
and celebrate yourself then you can use
your your time in our military to
empower yourself through the transition
for the rest of your life
be proud of your scars and once they
started doing this which there are guys
who are like in our rooms and we were so
proud I helped rescue American POWs and
somebody else Nate Boyer said I was
proud that I went back in after my time
was up to take the place of somebody who
may have had a family a wife and kids
somebody else there saying that we were
proud of we protected the first-ever
democratic election in Iraq and went off
without a hitch and somebody else saying
and we threw these girls and little kids
in Baghdad who just worked like helping
them throughout the streets but had
nothing I know shooting up just and they
together came around and washed these
kids feet and got them sandals for the
first time I'm proud we could do things
like this humanitarian lives and man
whoever you are out there and we're
trying to start the message within our
doors but really spread the message
strongly if you have served for your
country if you've done anything you find
something that that you could be proud
of I don't care what it is
find something you'd be proud of to move
forward and use that in your next step
of life because you are worth it you are
too brother
thanks for calling in stop by here you
were on your way up you're gonna pass by
our studios so if you want just oh good
I pick up my autographed copy of frozen
from you that's you got it Jake anything
for you everybody backs into it's a Jay
Glazer out Jay Glazer vets
players dorg the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience